hi guys I'm here with a very special
guest uh Thomas or Toma because he is
Belgium so his native language is French
um Toma can you please introduce
yourself uh to to the audience and tell
us who you are and what do you
do hi everybody my name is Thomas uh as
Lucas said I come from Belgium from the
south part of Belgium which is called
wona which isans that my mother tongue
is French this is important for the rest
of it uh and I moved to Budapest
actually exactly four years ago since it
was the 1 of September 2019
coincidence
yes I I work here as a French translator
and voiceover
artist and um apart from that I uh have
some YouTube channels about Hungarian
stuff about singing uh and other
interesting things I'm a literary
translator uh and uh yeah and I love
singing that's the best I could Define
myself you said you have multiple
YouTube channels so one for singing one
for language learning one for exactly
yes not mixing everything we will put
the the links in the description box for
those who are interested to check your
stuff now one thing that I wanted to say
before we get into the interview is
actually two things first I met Toma at
the polylove Gathering last year and
then it so happened that I you know
after that because we we met in Poland I
would go to Budapest and he told me hey
I'm in Budapest and why don't we meet
and we met and we had a lot of fun it
was really interesting and we had a lot
of interesting conversations and one of
the most interesting things that tomat
told me is how he learned Hungaria now
before we talk about that how fast you
learn and the whole program and you know
all the things that happened in his life
when he moved to Hungary exactly four
years ago 1 of September right four
years ago um how many languages do you
speak and um you know in general because
I know that you speak a bunch of
languages you can speak them well so
let's let's start with that
question well that question in itself is
a can of worms as you know among po Lots
what is it to what does it mean to speak
a language if you consider that speaking
a language is having being able to have
a conversation with someone a fluent
conversation then in that sense I would
say six languages so as I said my mother
tongue is
French um English uh came after I would
say Hungarian and Russian right now are
kind of uh on the same level and uh
Dutch and German which are the two other
national languages of Belgium uh right
now they're kind of not in the best
shape I would say and apart from that uh
some languages I gathered I lived a bit
in Czech Republic uh I did my arasmus in
Bulgaria so Bulgarian as well and uh and
Turkish a little bit and Turkish a
little bit okay great so you have a very
nice background and I I know that you
speak languages well I I understand that
you know um when we when polygot say
what does it mean when you ask a poly
what does it mean to speak languages of
course speaking is debatable it depends
on the person but I can tell I can tell
you that I can tell the audience that
Tom speaks these languages really well
especially Hungarian and let's talk
about that so um when did you start
learning Hungarian exactly and how you
you've got a very interesting story you
know regarding
Hungarian unusual that's for sure uh
well actually I started
learning uh properly Hungarian uh just a
little bit more than uh four years
ago um so just to give you a little bit
on my background how I came to Hungary
basically I uh I was always interested
in languages since a very young age um
and I I was lucky enough to go to a high
school that was specialized in uh humity
so I had six years of Latin and ancient
Greek which was a solid background for
what I did afterwards I was already used
to declensions different grammatical
systems Etc and for etimology that was
really
beneficial uh I studied Uh Russian and
German at University in
Brussels uh I did three years uh for my
bachelor and I spent my arasmus in
Germany although to be fair my heart was
always beating more towards Russian I
had really amazing teachers which were
really
enthusiastic uh and that really led me
towards Eastern Europe let's say to that
part of the
continent um afterwards I uh was living
one year in Vienna I had a sabatical
year after getting my degree in Brussels
um and I chose Vienna because I wanted
to improve my German but also to
discover this part of Europe I had no
idea what was there I knew nothing of it
just a little bit about the Habsburg uh
family Empire Etc I read many books
about it and I was very curious to see
it firsthand so while I was studying and
working in Vienna I was traveling a lot
I went obviously to Slovakia Croatia uh
Slovenia and of course to Budapest to uh
Hungary and that was in
2014 that's the first time I uh put my
feet on the Hungarian ground and from
the very start
I was this was very overwhelming for
many reasons it had a huge
impression uh it left a huge impression
on me first of all the city itself I was
kind of expecting something the size of
Zagreb or Bratislava and here I come
into this Megapolis with a huge river
between the two sides of the city
especially since I come from a very
small town in Belgium I was really
amazed
uh but also by the language and that's
where our story
starts uh I had I guess everybody has
this very Vivid moment to come in uh in
contact with with the language for the
very first time for me it's as if I was
there uh today I still remember it very
vividly I was taking my bus the naplate
bus station I went to take the metro
which looked very Grim at the time and I
started reading those advertisements on
the windows and at the time I was very
naively thinking well I can make my way
in Europe I know Germans or Germanic
language I you're Russian I can make my
way in any Slavic language and I know
French so Roman languages are fine and
here I come I stumble upon this language
that's nothing like I ever saw before
with weird consonant clusters in
combination like a zed after an S like
what is
this and it instantly caught my attenion
there was something happened in my brain
I was very interested at that stage it
didn't go further than that but I was
like okay I need to know more about this
language I was there only for a few days
so I didn't have time to learn it in any
way shap of form
I came back to Vienna and this idea
stayed in the back of my mind for the
upcoming years um I studied I got a
master in international
relations I did an internship in Russia
for three months I worked in Czech
Republic but my job there wasn't exactly
what I was
expecting I always wanted to go back to
my first love which was language
learning and aeal
uh pure language learning because I did
that in my bachelor but we had a bunch
of courses like about law economics Etc
there there were many subjects that had
nothing to do with Linguistics and
that's what I wanted from the
beginning and I had a serious life let's
say in prag I was 26 already I was like
I have to be serious and have a flat Etc
but my heart said okay this is maybe the
last chance you can uh do what you
actually want to do with your life but
how how to achieve this so first of all
I was like which language hen seemed a
very interesting choice because
everybody around me was like yeah this
is the most difficult language in Europe
many people described it as such and I
experienced it firsthand so I was like
well is it really the most difficult
language in Europe
I I have to see it for myself so I got
more and more in contact with it
especially through music I started
listening to artists on
Spotify uh and I liked it more and more
like especially the melody of it like
this uh alternance between consonants
and vowel consonant vowel that's
something I never experienced before but
the question was okay how to do this in
a serious way because Hungarian is
very difficult that's what everybody
says so I can either study it in Prague
and pay a private tutor but to get a
good level maybe it would take me three
or four years and probably a lot of
money or maybe they would be a way to
actually move to Budapest but how like
what would I do there and so I was uh um
lucky enough to I mean I subscribe to
some groups on Facebook like I learn h
Hungarian and that kind of groups
usually I don't go to social media very
often but one day I open my feed and
there was this uh publication like there
there's this scholarship program
organized by the bosi in bosi Institute
to learn Hungarian intensively for one
year and not only the language also the
culture the history the literature Etc
and I saw this I was like this is
exactly what I'm looking for like I want
to make progress as fast as possible but
it also said it's mostly geared towards
University students who have a solid
background in Hungarian which I wasn't I
had zero background in
Hungarian so what I did is I contacted
some friends I got recommendation
letters from them I applied very shortly
before the deadline that's the craziest
thing of all it was two weeks before the
deadline and I got a nice email and I
was rejected I was on the waiting
list so I was like okay this was a nice
pipe dream at least I tried but uh turns
out I was like okay I'm interested in
the country anyways I'm going to go
there for the summer I spent two weeks
there there was a small summer
University like just to get acquaint a
little bit with the
culture but I met some people from The
Bash
Institute and especially the secretary
Shar tund if you watch this video you
kind of changed my life and she came to
me and she told me at the very end of
that uh summer University she told me by
the way somebody just retracted from the
scholarship and you're the next one on
the list so if you want the place is
yours and I said yes and that's how I
ended up in Hungary just in a
nutshell amazing um now there's U you
know some bells ringing you probably
can't hear it and I hope it will not be
in the recording because I have some
noise constellation but background noise
but you never know anyway so because I'm
in CCO here um and just in front of a
big church regardless of that amazing
story really interesting now let's get
into it cu um you know I always Advocate
that people should learn every single
day and that's fine but a lot of um a
common problem a recurring problem that
a lot of students and language Learners
have in general is that they don't see
progress that fast right because because
we have a lot of things to do and if
unless they live in country unless they
have the privilege of you know either um
you know signing up to a a very
intensive program or living in country
it's kind of difficult to be able to
dedicate two three four hours and you
know immersion in the language but I
believe that when you're able to emerse
from the from the get-go you can get you
can get there fast now in your case when
you what you told me last year was
basically that you started this very
intensive program so I'm very curious
about that how you learned and also you
then used um you got to know your
exgirlfriend for from Turkey right mhm
and then uh you started speaking with
her in Hungarian because she wasn't the
same in in you know in the same program
right so the I I have a couple of
questions how did you start was it
difficult at the beginning did the
teacher speak just in uh Hungarian did
you have to speak just in Hungarian with
the other students and what happened at
the beginning because I can imagine that
if you do not speak a word of Hungarian
right like from the GetGo or you know
some Hungarian right even if you know
some Hungarian isn't it difficult to do
everything in Hungarian or was there any
some some stuff maybe some materials in
English or sometimes if someone did not
understand they could raise their hands
and say can I use English how did that
unfold the whole thing first and then
we're going to talk about intensity and
making progress and using the language
in real
life so to give you a little bit of
context I joined the A2 group which is
almost a complete beginner group but uh
we made uh progress very fast the stress
was put on speaking only Hungarian in
the classroom actually many teachers
barely spoke English which made
everything easier in a way um and but
obviously it was you know student
friendly we were everybody was from a
different country a different background
they were talking very very slow and we
were using some books uh we were
using Li and M very good one if you if
it rings a bell so with a lot of
illustration can you show it please can
you can you show me just the title for
example this Le K Le K
Le yes uh that was uh the main book we
used uh but there was another one that I
was using at the very beginning it's
called Hungarian in words and
pictures uh that I just downloaded from
the Internet is pretty old so it was
pretty funny because they still had um
some constructions that were very
communist with f which means comrade
basically but the point of the
Communist in Hungarian you would say oh
sa regy like good old times but the what
was very good about this book it was is
that it was almost only in Hungarian
with plenty of pictures like the title
indicates uh and I made really a lot of
progress thanks to that so I would say
that it was an a total immersion uh in
the language not only in the classroom
but also outside like I was uh
especially at the beginning I had some
progress to make to be at the same level
well as my
classmates um and that uh that really
helped because especially in
Hungarian Hungarian is very I would say
a very logical language but as a um my
tutor my French
tutor uh puts it very nicely is the kind
of language where you have to forget
your own mother tongue for it to make
sense since it's not even an
Indo-European language the structure is
completely different it's agglutinative
like other languages like Turkish so
unless you are ready to put aside
everything you know about Linguistics
and sentence construction Etc you're
going to have a very very hard time
that's also the reason yeah this is a
very good point now let me ask you
before we continue and sorry to
interrupt you I want to ask you some
more specific questions about what
happened in class so first of all how
many people were in each class class or
in your
class in my class we were about nine if
I remember correctly from Turkey Japan
Korea um you know everything mixed from
did you have different teachers how many
teachers did you have we had one uh
teacher that was assigned to a group a
very good one and she was always um
trying to match our interests so there
was no fixed program she was really adap
ing her uh teaching material to us which
was can you give me an example of of
what it
means um for example she um saw that we
were all interested in um geography like
about uh talking about certain countries
so she organized this uh presentation
where uh everybody would present his uh
Hometown but also discuss the the
politics for example something easy
something easy for something easy that
was towards the end of the year towards
the end of the year yeah um but also
yeah for example if there was a national
holiday in one of our countries uh I'm
not very good with the Muslim uh uh
holidays but for there was Ramadan or
something like this and she was bringing
material to uh you know engage uh the
students in the class who were who were
Muslim for example um that kind of stuff
and also celebrating birthdays so so
that we felt included at uh at every
time excellent I like that so she did
not present things that she thought
would be interesting she she asked you
what is interesting and then you talked
about it which is fantastic now let's
talk about the how so can you walk me
through what happened like she walked
into the class and then she said today
we're going to talk about this and then
she went like Toma can you tell me
something uh was she did everyone have a
chance of speaking first and when you
spoke and you froze and you couldn't say
something what happened when you did not
understand something what happened so
it's about understanding and getting
your point
across well for example if it was uh I
mean we usually started the day with
what did you do yesterday or what did
you do this weekend and we were asked to
prepare that
material uh in advance now I have to
stress out that there were many
homeworks uh every every single week uh
stuff to do and that was uh part of it
so we would prepare the vocabulary of
what we did the last day start the day
with that to have the basic vocabulary
in case we did we didn't know how to say
something uh she would help us or even
more probably other students uh would
you know uh whisper the the the correct
words Etc but it was uh especially at
the beginning it was uh very useful to
to to have this help coming from uh from
the others because well obviously I mean
just forming one sentence in Hungarian
is an extremely complex thing when you
start from from nothing so yeah we
started from the most basic structures
you can possibly imagine right and from
there just started extrapolating into
more complex ones excellent how many
hours did you spend per day did you do
it every single day yeah uh you have a
class every single day and how many
hours U every day yes if I remember
correctly it was four three or four
hours of Hungarian language classes and
then in the afternoon we had the other
subject
so history we even had
a Hungarian Society like about social
classes uh we had one about music
Hungarian neog like folk songs oh yeah
uh so as I said it was Encompass
encompassing all of Hungarian uh culture
because the goal of this program was
basically to make us fully
fledged
um I
not expats but that we would be ready to
enter the Hungarian job market and have
a very solid foundation to either ask
for nationality or really the whole
package okay fantastic so this was what
was happening inside right so in the
classes let's say um one last question
about the classes you were not allowed
to speak English
right um not not allowed but uh it was I
mean if we would say something in
English that would be okay but we we
knew that the rule was not to speak
English so if the rule was not to speak
English and you could not resort to
English or any other language again when
you did not know how to say something
did people also understand what you
wanted to say let's say that you know
you did not know how to say a word maybe
some some somebody understood what you
wanted to say or maybe they suggested
you can say this you can say that
um that's my understanding right of just
using your target language yes and we
had the computers in class I mean if you
don't know a word you just Google it or
something okay so you could do that so
you could do that okay so that's that's
an important thing uh this is what I do
for example when I have conversations in
Hungarian with my Hungarian teacher or
my Serbian teacher if I don't know
something I ask but I can also look it
up you know and normally I try to
anticipate this is a very important
point that I do all the time I try to
come up with a topic beforehand so that
once you know the topic you already look
up a number of words and expressions
that are related to that so you're
prepared so the fact that you came
prepared and you had to do homework is
really important because I believe that
when you do homework you're already come
prepared and it facilitates the class
and it makes you more like receptive to
the words and expressions so that's
wonderful now you also told me last year
that what really made a difference is
what happen outside of class because I
can imagine that you have all these
students from all walks of life from
everywhere around the world what
happened when you got outside after a
few months that you started speaking
fast and we will talk about then
intensity and progress you know a bit
later but what happened did you speak
Hungarian naturally did you speak
English were some people you know some
people wanted to speak English to relax
a little bit or their own native
language maybe you met some some French
guys or French girls who wanted to speak
French uh
or everything was in Hungarian and you
guys were committed and saying I want to
speak Hungarian even outside to get the
you know the best out of the
situation that's that's a very good
question because it really varied wildly
among students because we were from all
different backgrounds some of them uh
were there just for one year just to you
know have just exploring Europe and
having no real goal in mind um but some
others like I'm thinking about uh um a
Russian guy in my class who became a a
good friend yarina who was paying for
the cor course herself she didn't get a
scholarship so obviously she was
extremely motivated and together we were
really trying to make the best out of
this situation and trying to uh use
Hungarian whenever we could sometimes we
spoke in Russian but uh that wasn't the
the main rule so some students barely
spoke English so we we could only speak
Hungarian between us which made it even
more interesting so I would say
depending on the on the people I would
say 50/50 when we were outside of the
classroom and without the teacher
because there were a lot of field trips
uh going to see museums Etc where uh
obviously if the teacher was there we
would speak Hungarian uh Among Us when
did you start feeling that you started
making progress immediately after a few
weeks after a few months this is as I
said before the main point and also the
reason why I decided to talk to you is
about intensity is about to talk about
intensity in language learning don't you
think that yes learning every day is
great but if you spend four hours five
hours only speaking your target language
or using your target language listening
to your target language you can learn
much faster and you see much faster
results yes uh that was also the whole
plan behind this uh I mean this decision
to go to hunger for one year is that I
knew that learning it with a tutor would
take way way longer and I could see
progress very fast uh I mean we're
probably going to talk about that later
but uh as you mentioned I was in a
relationship where I was only talking in
Hungarian with my partner and um that
required uh really a lot of vocabulary
even for everyday stuff yes uh and uh
yeah so I would say even one or two
months after starting this program I
could have really basic conversation
starting from absolutely zero because I
got input in my in my ears all day
long which I can understand stand is not
for everyone it can be overwhelming at
times um but you kind of have
to have to know when to rest your brain
a little bit you cannot catch every word
that's impossible you kind of have to
put yourself at ease and switch it off a
little bit I'm listening to Hungarian
but what is said is you know it's none
of my business something like that right
and uh the point is you gets into that
mindset where okay I heard that word
even passively I'm going to try to use
it the next time and like and when you
start from zero this is very encouraging
obviously every day I could you know I
was going through books or whatever some
material every single day there were
words that I didn't know the day before
so that really kicks you and give you
give you that nice energy that keeps you
going because you're using the language
right so before we talk about uh what
happened with your ex well not you know
not what happened with your ex Turkish
girlfriend but what happened in terms of
do you want to know not the details but
before we talk about that could you tell
me like you you you correctly pointed
out that it can be overwhelming so can
you tell me pros and cons of such an
intensive program and by the way for
those who are interested if we find if
you have the link we will post it in the
in the in the in the description box I
would like to take this intensive
program that would be nice I don't know
if I have the time to do it for an
entire year but I know from my Hungarian
teacher that there are intensive summer
programs that can last one to three
months in Deen for example um there's in
Deen also in Budapest but I've been to
Budapest so many times so maybe
exploring Bud Deen or some other Peach
some other uh places might be nice
anyway um let's go back to what I was
saying before what are the pros and cons
when you think from your perspective and
also if you have experienced and seen
firsthand some people getting stressed
um dropping out of the program or being
discouraged because they thought they
were not making progress or they were
having a hard time speaking and
understanding the language during this
intensive
program um let's start with the the pros
I truly believe they are only almost
only Pros doing that kind of program
obviously if you have the time for it uh
the first gr Pro is the exposure as we
mentioned having the language in your
ear every single day the gain of time
and money is AB absolutely tremendous in
I mean if your goal is to actually use
the language actively then you're you're
sparing yourself a lot of time and and
money and third and that might be the
most interesting Pro if you live in the
country and you you you have to use the
language with the locals for example if
you go to a shop you you have the actual
need of the language you have to make
yourself understood whereas with a tutor
you you can make mistakes you're going
to be corrected anyways so it puts your
your brain at ease and it's like okay I
can make mistakes where I here obviously
you also want to show that I respect
your country I speak Hungarian uh and
the most important thing you want to get
point across and you want the person to
understand you which brings language
learning to another level H especially
at the beginning for me it was almost
survival like because especially in
Budapest there are some people who don't
speak English at all whether in the
public
transportation or some other fields so
in those situations you you just have to
use it and it's a further
motivation for the cons as I said it can
be overwhelming sometimes I know for a
fact that I mean there were some
students who were speaking only in
English outside of the class because it
was more of a holiday for them but also
it was kind of a chore to speak the
language all the time so different
mindset there's nothing wrong with that
like different goals um but also also I
I would say
it's uh it's it's not a good program if
you're too perfectionists because I mean
that's the the essence of language
learning you have to make mistakes to
learn uh so especially I mean I'm not
going to quote any country or stuff but
some Asian countries Sometimes some
students wanted to create a perfect
sentence sentence taken from P fishand
or some poetry you know and speak like
they would be a native Hungarian which
is obviously impossible if you're in
that mindset then you're going to have a
real really hard time because obviously
our brain is not always fresh especially
after three hours of speaking Hungarian
in the classroom you are going to make
mistake and your brain is going to be
tired as hell but that's the that's the
name of the game got it okay great uh
great point now let's talk about um you
know using Arian um with your Turkish um
your EXT Turkish girlfriend uh by the
way we have a video uh that there's a
video on YouTube where you try to speak
with her was three years ago I think you
published that video on YouTube on your
YouTube channel so if you're interested
uh you can click in the on the link in
the description box to take a peek at
how tomma and his uh girlfriend at the
time were communicating in Hungary now
um let's talk about that for a second um
I was recently talking to a friend of
mine Simon here in um in crackle he's
Italian he's from tourin and we were
talking about the fact that you know
there's this this myth that if you have
a girlfriend uh that either speaks your
that's speaks your target language or is
native right that in that language then
and you live in country so you live in
the country where your target language
is spoken you're bound to learn but that
is not necessarily true right because
for example
in Simon's case I think Simon has a low
B B1 level but still difficult you have
to be proactive right if you want to
speak the language because when you
start a relationship now your case is
very special I believe because most most
couples I I know they're like the
language in the middle is always English
maybe one is from Colombia the other one
is from Hungary they meet they speak
English then unless both of them speak I
don't know a language French say for
whatever reason um they have another
common language the most common language
is English right in your case though it
was not it was Hungarian so and both of
you got to know each other in that
program right so and the reason why you
started speaking Hungarian was it
because she did not speak English that
well or because she did but she did not
want to use English because you were in
the program where that they will slap
you and whip you if you spoke on so to
speak or like what happened so that's
the first re the first question is
what's the reason why you started
speaking Hungarian with one another and
the second one is how was it to use
Hungarian um at the beginning if both of
you did not speak it that well right was
there any misunderstanding were
sometimes frustration involved in the
process um so first of all she um she
was in the same program as me but she
was uh really Advanced she was in the
literary translation program that I did
the year after but she had studied
Turkish at the University in Ankara for
quite some time and she she had a
tremendous
level uh so when we met um basically as
I said I was starting from zero uh and
uh yeah there was not a lot of talking
involved when with the whole
seduction part Etc but afterwards it
when it became real and we're like
together uh that's when the interesting
part started because finding uh topics
to talk about it just brought the whole
Ling language um live uh live like to
another level because it's very
different uh having to speak in a
classroom about fictive
uh real time
situations and trying to say to explain
something funny to your girlfriend for
example to make her laugh you know or
talking about important stuff like did
you close the door or do you want me to
get you something from the shop or that
kind of really important
information
um so I would say I I can say with
confidence that I wouldn't have the
level have right now uh without uh this
whole uh relationship and this active
use of hungar outside of uh the
classroom and uh yes we decided to talk
only in Hungarian that was very straight
from the beginning but as you mention I
have countless examples of people you
know with a hungan wife or vice versa
who don't even want to learn the
language because they they they started
speaking uh in English at the beginning
and from there it's very very hard to to
go another way got it so yeah that's
that's the way the cook crumbled I think
for the best linguistically but uh yeah
it's um I I definitely think it's a it's
a great way to learn a language even
more activ it is it is that's the reason
why you learn it so well one of the
reasons why I learn it so well because I
remember when we met you you were
speaking talking to people um and I was
like Wow uh Tomas speaks really well um
so another couple of questions that I
want to ask you um do you have any tips
for Learners who want to learn a little
bit faster so if someone's let's say
once has been learning say French or
Hungarian or German for quite some time
what would you recommend when it comes
to making progress in general like like
people get discouraged a little bit when
they don't see progress right so what is
it what is what is your piece of advice
one for learning a little bit
faster if they cannot uh afford a
program like the one you took and two
how do you keep motivated how do you how
do you uh how do you see progress um or
how can you find a way to perceive
progress to perceive Improvement and
that is the thing that you know propels
you forward to give you an example um in
in the last few weeks I'm trying to lose
weight and for me there's safety in
numbers in the fact in the fact that in
the sense that I can actually see on the
scale that my my uh you my weight is
going down right we talked about this
about losing weight but when you when
you see progress like you can see like
oh it's a Concrete thing I can see a
number changing that's one thing in
language learning though it's a little
bit more difficult to see um Improvement
you can perceive it but how do you how
do you measure Improvement in language
learning so two things here again what
are your tips for people who want to
speed up a little bit their language
learning uh you know process and two how
do you um do you have any strategies
to create a perception of improvement or
how how do you assess your improvement
in language learning in
general um my first tiep which is
connected to the second um question is
you basically need to have a goal if you
don't have a goal in my case at least
you're basically
delaying progress like if you have a
very precise goal in my case it was to
pass the B2 exam the Hungarian uh get
the B2 certificate at the end of this
program period that was it and so this
got me all the motivation I needed
because I didn't have much time on the
side I knew that it was a once in A-
lifetime opportunity and that every uh
minute that I was spending in that
program was basically a gift and that if
I wouldn't exploit it I I mean nobody
will do it for me you know what I mean
so I had one year to achieve this goal
and with that in mind like I was even
putting it on on my wall to have it uh
always in mind that really boosted my
energy and
motivation
um my my second tip which is valid for
people in a intensive program like me
but also in general and that uh is
something that many people underestimate
I think is to find the right input like
you really especially in a program like
mine you had to stay relaxed because as
we said you're bombarded with input day
in day out and if outside of the
classroom you start watching videos that
you're not really interested in or that
you feel forced to watch because yeah
I'm in Hungary I should know about this
and that throw it out of the window
that's that's the best way to get
discouraged because it takes a lot of
your energy and what if you have to
spend even more energy outside of the
classroom you're going to make a burnout
at some point yes you're going to split
your differential or something so it's
super important to find your input in my
case I found uh for example I was
reading mangas which is not Hungarian at
all mangas in Hungarian I was reading
Dragon Ball why because you just want to
know the rest is not important what
happens and it's just very easy to
follow uh unlike a proper book I also
downloaded mods for some video games
like I was playing GTA 5 in Hungarian
which was excellent for my slang there
was lot of there was a lot
of I mean insults and like Street streak
lingo Etc so that really helped me and
also I played The Witcher 3 the polish
game I was playing it with the Polish
voice and the Hungarian text but never
more than 30 minutes so I was on Steam
if you play video games you know it you
can you can change the language whenever
you want and not to be overwhelmed I was
just playing you know for 30 minutes max
with a sheet of paper next to me if
there was some really interesting
expression or oh that sounds interesting
I want to uh look it up I was writing it
down down and after 30 minutes I was
coming back to French not to overheat
basically so really that's uh that phase
is the most crucial I think and you have
to to ask yourself what am I interested
in uh the third one uh that's just the
way I
work the the way I did it is that uh the
way I learned any language is that I
create a document on google doc and I
put all the information I get know about
the culture sent it to me and I loved it
I loved it it's just amazing yeah please
continue
sorry no wor but uh for me is such a
peace of mind because I put all my
vocabulary there uh pronunciation fun
facts everything I need uh in just one
document instead of writing in on small
papers that I might lose afterward words
like where did I write this word uh with
this document first of all I can put it
on my computer or on my phone so I have
it on the GetGo if I go to a museum for
example oh I think I saw that word
before Ctrl F in my document I find it
if I don't find it well write it down uh
I mean uh write it in the document later
on and um what did I want to say yeah
yes uh it's it just helps you to know
what you the words that you already saw
before and and the ones you didn't it
happens to me all the time like just
before this interview for example I was
uh reading an article in Hungarian and
there was this uh very fancy word and I
was like there's no way I I don't know
this word I'm going to check it in my
document and turns out somehow I don't
know when maybe three years ago I came
across it and I wrote it down which
brings me to my last tip which is the
most important one if you have this
passive knowledge these lists of
vocabulary that you never look into it's
useless it's dead knowledge you might
recognize the words because oh okay I
saw it before but what what we want is
use them actively and the best for that
is to use some flashcards apps in my
case I use ke which works really well so
whenever I see a word that is in my list
which means I saw it before it aat
automatically goes into my deck on Anki
which will transform this passive word
into an active one and will come up in
my deck maybe to tomorrow or the next
month and this way you keep it going and
you invest I mean you you uh you can use
all these words that you you saw
beforehand a true language lover I would
say Tom you're a true language lover I
love that like the interest the passion
you know some a lot of people do it
because sometimes they want to do it yes
that's fine but or they have to do it
but when you really really really want
to do something you really are
interested in something you find all
possible ways creative ways to make the
language get in you and you are one of
the true language lovers I would say so
um we had said at the beginning that
this interview would last 20 to 30
minutes but it's so interesting that
actually we've been speaking for 47
minutes right now uh so um I still have
three more questions I still don't know
whether we're going to divide this into
two parts or not maybe we're going to
keep it in just one hour thing let's try
to keep it within the hour mark I have I
joted them down here I have a thousand
questions that popped up in my mind but
maybe we can talk about them another
time for now I have the next next three
questions are let's try to keep it
concise otherwise this is going to last
forever even if it's super interesting
Icelandic program I know that you went
to Iceland I know because we have a
friend in common who goes by the name of
Richard simcard and he went to the same
program I saw some pictures I think of
of you in the program and some pictures
of Richard back in back in time and I
wanted to ask you about that next
language or languages you want to learn
and what do you think about language
certifications we touched upon this a
little bit I guess that you are you like
language certifications but let's see so
first let's talk about the very briefly
about the icing program how was it were
you a beginner why you decide to learn
Icelandic and if you liked it and was it
it as intensive as the one in
Hungarian so uh to uh put it short this
Icelandic program was basically the
equivalent of what they did in the Bashi
but in one month it's a program
organized uh by the AR Magnuson
Institute which is responsible for
everything linked to Icelandic culture
and they organize this once a year uh in
the months of July so I was I spent all
July there and it's basically the same
concept in the sense that you have the
language part but also the cultural
part and I wanted to learn Icelandic for
quite some times uh for different
reasons I
absolutely love the way it sounds
actually the first time I came across uh
Old Norse so the ancestor of Icelandic
was with the Siri
Vikings there are some sentences oh no
and I was like what is this I never
heard anything like that so obviously I
needed to know more I Googled it and I
was like okay Icelandic seems to be the
closest language to Old Norse
interesting but how do I learn it
I applied to this program there was a
test at the beginning so uh I worked on
some islandic I didn't know anything but
for for two weeks I passed a text I was
accepted and this was the best decision
honestly it wasn't only
um a question of interest but since I'm
a translator I it's also my job it was
also business decision because my optic
would be to make literary translation my
make main source of Revenue and the the
thing I do is that I specialize in small
languages that are spoken by a very
little amount of people uh where there
is almost no competition whereas if I
would try to learn Spanish or Italian
for example well there are dozens of
people actually raised in the both
languages I mean how how can you compete
comp with that and Icelandic was a very
interesting
choice so I went there I did this was
the same program as Richard did exactly
10 years ago which was funny I met him
in aavik and uh honestly it was
brilliant and I can say with certainty
that Icelandic is by far more difficult
than Hungarian I can tell you that even
the pronunciation is an absolute
nightmare which is very I mean that I
knew what I was getting into but you can
say anything you want Hungarian is
fanatic you write what you what you say
Icelandic is the exact opposite of that
like if you if you think that French
spelling doesn't make sense then try try
Icelandic you're going to be in for a
surprise maybe Danish also I I started
Danish it's the pronunciation is a
nightmare like there's no correspondence
between how it's written and how it's
spoken you know yes it's uh I I I don't
know Danish but uh I mean it has a lot
of historical ties with Iceland uh but
the thing that really seemed the most
difficult for me is the number of
dentals like for example the the
sentence what does it means what does it
mean
it's so you have five dentals in three
words
okay okay so it was an amazing program I
please um if you have the link send it
to me and we will put it in again uh in
the description box who knows I might
actually take that uh I have another
friend Stefanos suigo who's an Italian
translator and polyl is an amazing guy
he knows Icelandic I recently read an a
book of an Italian guy who moved to
Iceland it's fast absolutely fascinating
you know he's a professor of Icelandic
and uh of you know literature Icelandic
literature absolutely fascinating okay
so Icelandic program uh next is there
any other language you want to learn in
in the future seems like a rhetorical
rhetorical
question there are always but uh next
two let's say the two you can see like
yes the next two uh the first one is
Spanish I've been delaying this for way
too long I mean I go to some polyglot
events like the conf the polyglot
gathering in po
and some people are like you speak
French as a mother tongue and you don't
know any other Roman language why this
would it would be so easy for you and
the answer is always the same like I I
didn't come across a good enough of a
reason to learn it that kind of stuff
but now I have a reason because I'm
going to visit their Hungarian friend of
mine who's doing his Erasmus in Chile
next semester uh in South America I
never left Europe except for Siberia but
this is going to be a big uh a big first
for me and guess what they speak in
Chile Spanish so I just started a little
bit on
dualingo uh I expect it's definitely not
as difficult as most of the language I
had to languages I had to learn before
even though Chilean Spanish uh I mean
some people say it's quite different
so I get into that I just started a few
weeks ago let's see how this goes and
the second one would be polish because
also because of ravik ravik is little
Poland actually you go there chances are
I mean you hear a lot of polish on the
streets there's a huge polish
minority and uh I made many polish
friends there and I love the culture I
go there at least once a year so enough
with the delaying it's time to learn
that language as well wonderful uh one
last question very briefly what do you
think about language certifications are
they useful would you use it a language
learning tools have they helped you in
the process of learning
languages um as I said it can be useful
but especially on a personal uh from a
personal point of view as I said that B2
certificate was my goal and that's what
I tended to but when it comes to getting
a job or when you you have to prove that
you're uh fluent or you have a certain
level in a language well honestly I
never needed it and and I'm working in
the linguistic sphere like for example
I'm now working as a French translator I
mostly uh work from English to French I
have zero English certification no tle
nothing and in the end it's just there
will be someone in the company or
someone to check on your actual level I
think the level you have on a
certificate maybe it can be an exam that
you you pass a long time ago if you if
you get into the mindset of yeah I I'm a
B2 in French because my paper says so
then it can be you know illusory I would
say um what counts as what you actually
know and people will know how to how to
test your knowledge and with that we can
conclude thank thank you Toma for this
wonderful interview I loved every moment
of it I think we're going to keep it
within the hour uh where can people find
you so that I can put the links in the
description box uh I have my three
YouTube channels one for Hungarian stuff
one for poems that I translate and read
out loud and one about my singing uh and
other than that um yeah Facebook
Instagram LinkedIn I I can I can give
you
wonderful okay um well thank you so much
uh and uh I will see you at the polyga
conference in Budapest in a month or
something like that yes and of oober
thank you to thank you thank you C out
so